c'est grâce aux déclarations des
policiers parties civiles dans ce
dossier mais aussi aux nombreux
témoignages que le 3e homme style st
juste 30 ans est écarté des accusations
de violences et entraîné la mort du
policier
louis-philippe une des rades il a tout
de même poursuivi pour rébellion et
actes de violence ayant entraîné des
incapacités de travail de plusieurs
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
monsieur st juste mérite une défense
mérite une défense et de toutes les
manières fosse avant que il y à des
faits mais il ya aussi la prévention il
est aussi le droit
on parle de violence moi je parle
uniquement de rebellions je vais pas
dire que c'est la faute à pas de chance
mais en tout cas il a suivi suivi ses
camarades parce qu'il souhaitait avoir
des explications concernant
l'interpellation de l'un de ses amis
et aujourd'hui il regrette d'avoir suivi
ces personnes là et aujourd'hui le tout
et manière y insérer dans la vie et il
va le dire devant la contenir
l'enquêteur de la police hier faisant
ressortir la détermination à la violence
des coups portés par les deux principaux
accusés aux policiers des rallyes
c'est là que c'est christopher nessma le
frappe à plusieurs reprises le ch est au
sol la soeur stacy lui saute dans le dos
ces violences sont à l'origine du décès
du fonctionnaire a précisé médecin
légiste la barre un frère et une soeur
l'aînée ce monde qui pour l'instant
n'ont pas été interrogés sur les faits
simplement sur les personnalités mais
qui pour l'instant n'ont donné que peu
de réponses ont montré effectivement que
ce jour là ils voulaient en découdre
en tout cas c'est ce qui résulte des
témoignages de quelques policiers qui se
sont succédé à la barre une agressivité
extrême et la volonté d'en découdre en
dépit du calme des policiers qui
essayaient de les inciter effectivement
et bien à davantage de modération
demain troisième journée d'audience
place aux experts et à d'autres témoins
très important dans ce dossier aux
assises